taj c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
un anti portrait chinois ne bouge
beaucoup porter chinois ça veut dire il
ya le portrait chinois si vous étiez une
fleur je serai aux autistes lentilles
portrait chinois par exemple c'est si
vous étiez un défaut si j'étais un
défaut mais si jason si j'étais d'un
défaut quel défaut vous seriez l'esprit
de sérieux je crois je crains que je
crains c'est bien si vous étiez
d'injures le silence si j'étais une
maladie la lucidité un accident la
chance une perversion
le goût du secret si vous étiez un vice
si j'étais un vis à la si belle fera le
si beau titre de larbaud ce vice impuni
la lecture si j'étais d'avis je serai la
lecture une trahison
je serai comme ces gens qui militent ou
qui se bat contre leur tribu contre leur
camp par exemple je ne sais pas les
aristocrates ou les prêtres français en
89 qui rejoignait de serre d'état c'est
une des plus belles attitudes me
semble-t-il ceux qui choisissent de
penser contre eux mêmes ou contre les
leurres penser contre soi même pensée
contraire oui ou contre les siens les
pieds noirs qui devenait porto qui
prenait le parti du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie
ça ça me semble une attitude très noble
si une arme
si j'étais une arme un stylo c'est le
seul dont je suis capable de me servir
c'est la différence entre vous et nabab
lula a répondu à 14 mois ce sera ou il
ya sûrement d'autres et différence mois
cette interview ça permet de si j'étais
un supplice la volupté une cicatrice le
souvenir notamment des volutes et si
vous étiez un poison la vérité dont
soljenitsyne disait qu'elle était le
poison des dictatures que les dictatures
se corroder par le travail de la vérité
se situe une panne je crois que
j'essaierai de dérégler d'envoyer un
virus dans les derniers ordinateurs de
ben laden ceux avec lesquels il est sans
doute en train de préparer ses prochains
attentats est un dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur j'oblige ray et
thierry ardisson a diffusé chaque samedi
10 minutes en boucle l'image de l'angola
et du burundi que je veux voir
si vous êtes une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité la surdité
réussir et une infirmité
non là l'impatience l'impatience moi
c'est probablement mon pire défaut et
voilà la patience grâce à ça si j'étais
un assassin jeu j'essaierai d'assassiner
pas ma voisine rassurez vous la mauvaise
part de moi-même que je connais bien et
ça en général c'est un crime parfait
mais celui là si vous étiez à microbes
j'essaierai d'être d'être un microbe
sympathique des train d'être un microbe
du gauche qui irait chercher de
préférence les [ __ ] et parfois les
ponts mais surtout les salles aux
microbes sélectif une torture je ne sais
pas si je voulais torturer quelqu'un je
crois que ce serait la différence
voilà une humiliation je me suiciderai
parce que je si j'étais minimisation jeu
mais je crois que je ne supporte ni
d'être humilié ni encore moins de
supporter l'humiliation des autres donc
je disparaîtrai dans votre nuage de
fumée jugement dernier serge lama
j'accompagnerai salamanque longue at war
singer temps
par aline et si vous étiez un terroriste
je serai le colonel fabien
c'est à dire je serai un bon terrorisme
la définition d'un bon terroristes c'est
quelqu'un qui défendent juste cause et
qui n'a pas d'autre moyen que la
violence de la défendre donc posé des
bombes dans paris en 42 colonel fabien à
ça je crois que c'est du bon terrorisme
et ça n'a évidemment rien à voir avec
cette caricature que sont les
terroristes d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer quoi
c'est comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer
qui était un mode malraux et qui est
elle a deux filles la devise du
commandant massoud ray et si vous étiez
une bourre 3 je serai très chaud serait
la petite mort
les damnés de la guerre
et chez grasset